hey guys what's up welcome to vlog
university now this is gonna be a
special vlog University because right
now something very special was going on
anybody want to take a guess nope no
guesses good want me to tell you VidCon
is going on right now in Los Angeles now
some of you guys might actually be there
so don't forget to say hi it's a big
convention of a bunch of youtubers who
are all getting together in one place
we're gonna meet we're gonna hang out
where you to say hi we're gonna party
we're gonna dance it definitely will be
a lot of dancing so your homework
assignment for this episode is to give
some tips and tricks on making videos
now if you don't actually have any tips
and tricks just make a video on what
you'd like to watch most here on YouTube
now the reasons is gonna be a vlog
University episode is because I'm gonna
actually be at VidCon and ask a few of
you people that are actually they're the
same question and use them in the next
episode last episode which was actually
amazing because you guys sent some
fantastic videos and it was to go out
and play with an imaginary pet hey fishy
you need fed you hungry
some of you actually used real animals
which means you're disqualified I said
no real animals imaginary only let's get
to it here's a few of my favorite videos
from the last homework assignment I told
you to go on the paper on top chamber
how many times do I have to tell you on
look how close you were great now I have
to go get the pooper-scooper squatchy
your sweaty its vault mourani catch me
ready
ready ready squatching
today imaginary dog
via
thank you guys for all of your amazing
submissions and don't forget if you
actually are at VidCon come say hi I
can't wait to see you and check out my
blog iJustine com I'll have all the
times listed that I will be around and
speaking and having meetups and other
than that don't forget to subscribe and
check out the rest of my youtube
channels and submit your vlog University
assignment in the form of video response
to this video here hmm if you want to
leave some comments as well saying what
you might like a future homework
assignment to be feel free to do that
hello okay